make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so Marvel recently released a
one-shot called Wolverine versus blade
or blade versus Wolverine is basically a
special it's a one-shot comic now here's
the deal for those people who have been
paying attention to what Marvel's been
doing Marvel's been releasing a lot of
content that features blade right like
blades been appearing a lot and usually
Marvel does that when a character is
going to appear in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe right it's one of those things
where like there's always kind of keep
up with each other and really like
Marvel comics kind of serves as a
preview for what's to come for the MCU
blades on the Avengers now like blade
and Wolverine or receiving like a
team-up and Wolverine is one of the most
popular characters right now so of
course copying the Fantastic Four theme
from the 1960s you put blade with
Wolverine and then just kind of call it
a day but this is not the first time the
two of them have ever teamed up or
really even met the reality is that
blade was always a character who kind of
free floated out there in Marvel for
like a number of years right I think
blade really was the most popular in
like the 1990s really when it was like
super high octane stories so like cable
and all those guys and like like
Wolverine like the antihero element
blade had dropped off really when the
1990s ended going in light of the 2000s
and and so he was really just sort of
there Marvel tried to Bevo his
popularity with the fifth volume of his
character and it was actually an issue
number five that they said that like
Wolverine and blade had actually met
when blade was younger in Philadelphia
and the trenchcoat and everything he
wears it really was an outfit that
originally belonged to Wolverine that
was given to blade so it was kind of
interesting kind of a weird little
retcon not super important but what this
does is it actually kind of capitalizes
on an old story from back in the day
like from vol 5 and the idea of
Wolverine and blade teaming up it really
comes by way of them facing off against
a group called the Creed now when it
comes to vampires in Marvel Comics
vampires usually always stick in like
groups right like groups or herds
whatever you want to call them and in
this instance it's only just a group
called the Creed now at the time the day
had faced off against them the Creed was
just one of several groups of late was
getting into a conflict with and
Wolverine was basically along for the
ride but it doesn't last very long right
I mean like this fight lasts you know
maybe a couple pages and like the Creed
or essentially like all but destroyed
and like Wolverine the only shoulders
cut like a chunk of a shoulders cut off
and it doesn't really matter I mean he
takes through and takes care of the
vampires pretty quickly and it ends
pretty fast and then following this we
jump forward six months later now this
is where things get intriguing because
what this six-month jump what we end up
getting into is is a fact like there's a
character by the name of Dragon s who's
brought in and she was actually really a
member of the Mutant Liberation Front
now the
Liberation Front was an organization
that was popularized and created in the
early 1990s with a launch of x-force
coming off of New Mutants and even then
maybe a little bit before New Mutants
but it was basically stripes stripes
mutant terrorist organization but the
idea here was that dragoness has
basically been turned into a vampire and
that's essentially it now along the way
when Wolverines tracking her down when
Wolverine goes after her one years of
finding is like this giant box I was
like kind of a skull looking thing on it
and so of course logically he takes it
to Doctor Strange now while all that
goes on you've also got blade continuing
to do his own thing now again blade was
always kind of an outlier blade was
always sort of fighting vampires and
unless you were really following like a
darker side of Marla right so like the
werewolf by night like the monster
themed element of marma comics which not
a lot of people did then you wouldn't
really be familiar with like blade in
the whole vampire side of things again
he was really always kind of like in his
own world ah but of course him facing
off against this this guy you know Count
von stat out in Germany somewhere von
said it turns out basically has like
laser eyes
he's got heat vision at least it seems
like and it's kind of weird because
vampires never really had that kind of
stuff and Marvel Comics vampires don't
really have abilities like that vampires
are a lot more straightforward they only
ever really come out at night they can
be killed by snakes and and silver and
so on and so forth they these things
that are the traditional vampire mythos
to a degree I mean not everything works
like a stake through the heart works you
know things along those lines but ah
this guy is essentially just kind of
like some grand pooh-bah here and when
blade asked the question where he got
his powers from you know where he has
these abilities from of course monster
nut refuses to answer and blade leaves
him in the sunlight he basically burns a
lot it's pretty straightforward I mean
it's not overly complicated I don't know
how to go super in-depth into this one
thing that is intriguing about this
though is the nature of blade so when it
came to blades character in Marvel one
of the things that you had to remember
was that he was almost kind of a by any
means necessary sort of guy right I mean
he wouldn't really like hold an innocent
person as a hostage against a vampire
that's not really something that he
would do but when it comes to vampires
it's I will kill them by any means
necessary he doesn't really care right
like if you were turned into a vampire
then he'll kill you
that's really the way it is whether it's
like an x-man or an Avenger or whatever
the case is like he'll go after you
because it's them the main charter of
his character it's his main mission it's
what he does and so one of the things
that he ends up finding out is that
where he and Wolverine previously
believed they destroy the Creed and
instead this guy has a Creed marking on
his chest and the result is that the
assumption of the belief is that the
Creed is still alive and functioning so
switching over to Wolverine
joining dr. strange again this is kind
of an interesting scenario because it's
really more Guggenheim kind of building
on the Doctor Strange mythos right like
when it comes to Stephen strange I mean
he is the sorcerer supreme really in
this day and age he's more the sorcerer
supreme by name only as opposed to power
right I mean and we were talking about
Doctor Strange in like the 1980s late
1970s or 1980s that we would say by
virtue of power because it was just that
powerful he could do pretty much
anything but after the war of the nine
realms I think it was when the vishanti
took away like like 60% of his power and
then gave a portion of it back but not
all of it he's kind of been deep Howard
ever since and so he's not nearly as
powerful as he was back in the day
really he can't do everything he can't
do anything he wants to there are limits
to his power ah but when we think about
Doctor Strange we usually only ever
really think of like magic and mysticism
now those who are very very experienced
readers do know that he was part of that
whole darker side of model right now I
mean a werewolf at night and all that
kind of stuff they know that he was
pardon that that darker kind of demonic
side of Marvel for a while the
information is available in that part of
the Marvel Universe is available to
Doctor Strange and he knows about it
right so he's not like walking around
oblivious to the nature of vampires it's
just something he doesn't deal with all
too often now when Marvel launched the
1990s version of the defenders which was
basically just a series of stories where
Doctor Strange had what what amounted to
like a black ops team that was composed
of like different members like wool rain
and different things like that that they
had fought threats that you wouldn't
normally see in a Doctor Strange story
and it was actually really cool for the
time if they brought it back it could
work exceedingly well right I mean
Doctor Strange has it has a a revolving
team of characters that consists of like
the Fantastic Four or some members of
the avengers like imagine Doctor Strange
and like The Incredible Hulk and like
Wolverine and Cyclops and I know Johnny
Storm who go on some mission somewhere
to fight some demonic entity or
something along those lines
it'd be interesting and they'd actually
be pretty intriguing if it was done
correctly the problem I t90 is that for
the most part it was not done correctly
and so that's why it wasn't all that
great but Doctor Strange basically says
this particular artifact this box
houses a whole bunch of magical energy
that is vampiric in nature and has been
designed to essentially like keep it
close but of course Doctor Strange being
the sorcerer supreme can open it up now
when he starts saying things about like
the Creed and about like variks and
things like that this is one him showing
that he knows what's going on to a
degree but to for the most part it's
really beneath dr. strange to get
involved and that's the question that a
lot of people would probably ask if
Doctor Strange is aware of all this then
why doesn't he act well because it's
really if there's no
reason for him to there's more important
things going on out there in the realm
of like magic and mysticism then like
vampires out in the West's are out in
the East somewhere or wherever it is
they happen to be
but what Stephen strange says is that
the entire vampire community and really
like I guess really just the creed for
the most part it has what's called
variks and variks is basically like
their Messiah now we can largely assume
that when it comes to like messianic
figures in vampire mythology that for
the most part they kind of have
different messiahs on you know who they
deemed to be the actual God but there is
there they're really kind of has to be a
God above gods with regards to like how
the vampires function and how they work
now this is kind of manifested in
various forms over the years most
recently this does kind of look like
Marcus right the like Marcus is like the
vampire above all vampires but we don't
really know what this has to do with
anything all we know is that the death
of variks basically comes by way of
Wolverine himself who seems to be the
one to kill him and so when you switch
over to blade blades basically
interrogating a guy named Desmond and
Desmond really spills the beans of the
other half of the equation that the
prophecy states that that variks is
basically a mutant turned into a vampire
and so because this a reason why Count
von stat had had you know heat vision or
concussive blast whatever you want to
call them is because what the Creed had
been doing was running around and
turning mutants into vampires under the
belief that they could basically awaken
variks they could discover who variks
actually is and discover their Messiah
so it's really kind of a dangerous game
because when you end up having Wolverine
and then you have blade basically track
down the Kree to their location they
both arrived there and each one thinks
the others Farkus now the reality of
this is that it's kind of thin and it's
not the best writing ever Wolverine and
blade are not like the sharpest tools in
the shed right I mean you know they're
you know unlike ninety percent or 99
maybe like eighty percent capacity right
but they're by no means like stupid and
so it seems kind of weird to put them in
a situation to where they're with both
show up here and because Vargas had a
sword and because Wolverine was killing
Farkas there they each interpreted it as
the other right is just kinda like okay
that's silly if anything I would say
this was just done for the purpose of
getting us a fight between blade and
Wolverine and the fight for the most
part is actually pretty evenly matched
and it's interesting the way that it's
done because under normal expectations
you would look at this and you would
expect Wolverine to win you'd expect him
to win like that like in blood quick
fast and in a hurry with no real
indication that blade could actually win
but remember when you know in the time
they've met over the years
Wolverine top blade a few things not
only that you also have blades abilities
in the fact
he's half vampire so that kind of boost
what it is that he can do at the same
time Wolverine kind of goes into this
like okay you know let's battle a little
bit but his heart's not necessarily into
it the only this blade gets thrown by
Wolverine ultimately like Wolverine
realizes hey this is one of the the
blades that blade uses in order to kill
a vampire he thinks I'm a vampire and
that's what the two of them kind of stop
fighting and reconcile I mean I don't
know if this is really designed to
answer the question who would win
Wolverine versus blade because the fight
kind of ends before it starts but one of
the things that I want you guys to
notice here in terms of how blade looks
is blade looks like Michael Jai White
and it's kind of crazy because again
like Marvel does that when they're
bringing characters into the MCU I think
Michael Jai White would be an amazing
blade like like do the guys okay here's
the thing
Michael Jai White is a legit martial
artist right like he's this really
really cool guy um he's got is these
like like a seventh degree black belt or
something like that he's been studying
martial arts for like 21 years let's do
the guy's a legit fighter right and I
mean like make him blade like I think
he'd be an amazing blade he'd be my pick
right he would be my pick is the guy has
to be able to move and fight and pull
off the kind of stunts the blade needs
to be able to pull off if you've never
seen Michael Jai White in action you
need to go look at his movies like you
need to go look him up the guy is a
legit fighter like he's a multi
tournament champ it's it's pretty cool
but in any event ah this basically leads
to like the arrival of Farkas himself
and that's what we end up finding out
here that what happened was that when
the chunk of Wolverines shoulder was cut
off that what the Kree did is they used
it to basically clone a new Wolverine
and when they did that they basically
said like this is our new Messiah simply
like we've got wolf ray now we've got a
vampire with a healing factor like this
is our thing now this works because
there is actually a what if story where
Wolverine becomes a vampire and turns
the rest of the world into vampires I'm
pretty sure but the fight ends like
really fast right I mean like it's not
even that long at all it's like a couple
of pages and that's that's kind of the
issue you run into with with stories
like this where blade and Wolverine team
up and they say okay you attack from the
from below I'll tack from high and they
cut off his head and get him at the same
time and he just dies the problem you
run into with stories like this is it's
really done more for either boosting a
character or for just like showing us a
depiction of a battle between two
characters but the issue with doing
something like this is it takes away
from this story right because if Marvel
starts dumping a whole bunch of blade
material based on the idea that they
want to get blade out there because he's
gonna be in the MCU but all the material
that comes out from blade sucks then
people aren't gonna care about him when
he comes into the MCU instead like if I
were them I would reprint the old blade
stories the blade stories back in the
day like blade volumes one
two and three they were legit like they
were awesome all the time you got two
four and five they sucked but lie blades
one two and three like they were awesome
like there were great stories from back
in the day and I would just reprint them
or we're like basically just like
continued on from like the original
blade series and just sort of like NYX
two and three if they wanted to but
unless it's interesting it's a cool
little story insofar as like blade and
Wolverine team up and fight each other
but it's again like for the most part
it's just kind of not the best thing
ever to come out of Marvel so without
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
comments explain make sure you guys are
the sub button to become part of the Rob
core if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]